avec nous Paul Baudry sous gouverneur de
la Banque du Canada bonsoir Monsieur
Baudry bonsoir donc on le voit dans les
chiffres le rythme de l'inflation qui
ralentit déjà au pays les 9 hausses
précédentes du taux directeur évidemment
n'ont pas encore produit leur plein
effet alors est-ce que c'était
absolument essentiel monsieur Baudry
d'augmenter encore les taux aujourd'hui
bon il faut vraiment voir qu'en pense à
augmenter le tour on regarde un ensemble
de changements dans l'économie puis fait
la balancer dans l'idée si on attend
qu'on attend trop tard il va falloir en
faire plus comme le gouverneur le dit
donc nous on essaie de balancer en ce
moment c'est encore le cas que
l'économie marche à trop grosse vitesse
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de pression à
l'inflation donc on avait l'impression
qu'en cas qu'il fallait réduire cette
vitesse là pour aider à réduire les
pressions d'inflation et ramener à une
situation qui est plus acceptable pour
les Canadiens les Canadiens qui sont se
le dit de plus en plus endettés les cas
d'un solvabilité sont en hausse il y a
des entreprises aussi qui repoussent
leurs projets alors comment on explique
monsieur Baudry que la consommation soit
encore si vigoureuse mais il faut
vraiment voir comme vous dites il y a
des gens qui pour lequel la situation
est très difficile et si on comprend ça
et on prend ça en compte mais aussi
beaucoup de gens qui ont réussi à
épargner à beaucoup pendant la pandémie
et qui ont encore cette épargne là
d'accumuler et en plus que le marché du
travail va bien mais ça permet aux gens
dire bon ben je peux me permettre
d'aller dépenser donc il faut vraiment
faire la différence c'est ça qui est la
difficulté en ce moment cette
hétérogénéité dans la population qui a
beaucoup de gens qui s'en vont consommer
qui dépensent et certains gens qui sont
vraiment pris où la situation est
difficile pour eux là c'est difficile de
faire face à la hausse des frais
hypothécaires par exemple et certains
ont l'impression que la Banque du Canada
s'acharne un peu sur leur sort en
quelque sorte je vais vous laisser
entendre quelques réactions
d'emprunteurs aujourd'hui monsieur
Baudry
en augmentant toujours toujours les taux
ça fait un peu pompier pyromane en fait
vous avez entendu cette dame monsieur
Baudry qui dit on est un peu à la merci
de la Banque du Canada qu'est-ce que
vous répondez au Canadien qui ont
l'impression d'être des beaux émissaires
dans votre lutte contre l'inflation on
écoute vraiment ce côté-là on comprend
on sait que c'est difficile pour les
Canadiens c'est difficile aussi le côté
de l'inflation est difficile pour
beaucoup de Canadiens aussi donc il faut
équilibrer les deux côtés il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont asseoir
revenus fixes ou que leur salaire ont
pas ajusté pour l'inflation qui ont
vraiment les difficultés d'arriver donc
en abaissant l'inflation on est tout un
groupe mais c'est certain que les
montées de tout pour y arriver c'est
quand même difficile sur d'autres
groupes on essaie de balancer ces deux
là au total on pense que qu'est-ce qu'on
fait c'est le mieux pour les Canadiens
en moyenne bon c'est particulier la
situation en ce moment parce que la
banque jusqu'à un certain point est en
partie responsable du mal quel combat
parce qu'on fait bondir le coût de
l'intérêt hypothécaire à un rythme
record ça grimpait presque 30% sur un an
et ça alimente ça monsieur Baudry
l'inflation non
c'est une partie mais quand on regarde
l'idée de l'inflation c'est vraiment un
effet de de prise généraliser qui monte
dans beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs et
quand on regarde en ce moment on a
encore beaucoup de secteurs ou ces
entraînent à augmenter rapidement on a
juste à aller à l'épicerie on s'aperçoit
les prix de la nourriture c'est encore
en train d'augmenter à peu près 9 10 %,
on va le coup du loyer c'était à peu
près 10% on a les si on veut prendre des
vacances cet été les restaurants c'est
comme 12%, les hôtels ça me ferait 12%
des restaurants c'est à peu près 7%,
donc on voit encore ce côté-là
d'inflation généralisée et c'est ça
qu'on veut contrôler on veut ramener on
veut ramener cette inflation plus plus
stable et ramener ça à 2%. c'est un
travail d'équilibriste on entendait tes
maclem me le dire aujourd'hui il faut
trouver le juste milieu en quelque sorte
entre le contrôle la maîtrise
l'inflation et cette volonté de ne pas
en faire trop de pas provoquer une
récession est-ce que c'est mieux d'en
faire un peu plus maintenant que pas
assez qui est à relâcher de la Bourse un
peu plus tard
on essaie de vraiment balancer on essaie
vraiment de s'assurer qu'on est pas en
train de resserrer plus qu'il faut mais
en même temps si on en fait pas assez on
attend ça risque de repartir l'inflation
et de besoin de faire plus dans le futur
et ça ce serait pas ce serait pas facile
à ce moment-là on sera encore dans une
situation avec plus d'inflation et plus
de taux encore plus élevé donc c'est
vraiment cette ce côté là qu'on veut
éviter mais en même temps on veut pas
resserrer pour si on n'a pas besoin là
on fait pas ça par plaisir on essaie de
trouver la solution qui est le plus
facile pour les gens bon évidemment
c'est votre mandat de ramener
l'inflation à la cible dans combien de
temps là l'indice des prêts à la
consommation dans la fourchette type de
la vente du Canada donc dans la
fourchette cible ce serait en ce moment
on croit que sur l'année suivante la
moyenne va se passer un petit peu au
dessus de 3% et à peu près dans un an ça
commencerait d'en fourchette cible ça
devrait tomber en dessous du 3 mais pour
vraiment revenir à deux pour avoir un
qu'on se retrouve pas toujours à carte
ou la 5 pour retrouver vraiment le 2 en
ce moment notre prévision c'est le
milieu de 20-25 bon et dans les chiffres
je le signale une croissance toujours
supérieure à 1% dans l'horizon qu'on
peut voir venir donc on semble écarter
le scénario d'une récession on va
s'arrêter là-dessus monsieur Baudry
signal d'ailleurs que vous quittez la
Banque du Canada à la fin du mois après
quatre années à ces mouvements et je
vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir été là
pour nous au cours de ces dernières
années merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]